is kevin colbert kevin welcome back
what's going on mike glad to be here oh
great to talk to you always look forward
to talking to you after the draft this
year though
different than usual can you help
the non-scouts the non-football people
understand just what a challenge this
year was in comparison to a normal year
well you know when you look back on 2019
we had a normal fall we had a combine
and then of course the pandemic hit and
we had to shut down the pro days
this year
we were able to get out in the fall
albeit in a different
format which was fine we could get at
least to get to see some live looks
we didn't have a combine but we had pro
days and the pro days were restricted on
the number of people that could go and
your your ability to access the players
so it's been different
but we were able to get all the
information
that we could
and hopefully we used it in a good
manner
what does it mean for a team to not be
able to have the private workouts it's
now been two years without those
yeah you know what i i really can't
answer that because we don't subscribe
to the private workouts in our opinion
if a player participates in the combine
and he goes to his pro day and
participates there that's enough for us
if we can't figure it out from those two
exposures then we're probably not
good enough at what we do so we've never
used the private workouts and we never
will either
well you managed to figure out based
upon the available information that not
jay harris was the pick in round one i
love the fact that it was 49 years after
frank o'hara's was the first round
running back and it's clearly an area of
need what is it that attracted you to
the alabama running back naji is you
know he's a a well-rounded running back
that played in a pro system he made nfl
runs routinely and he could also play in
in the passing game both as a receiver
and a blocker he's basically a
a three down back in an nfl or coming
from an nfl-like system and plugging
into a similar type system so he made
nfl runs at the collegiate level he did
it at a at a high level he helped them
win a national championship so hopefully
he can help us win some games
you know a couple of years ago nick
saban the alabama coach told bill
belichick in a documentary on hbo that
he's surprised how few coaches and
scouts actually call him did you guys
tap into nick saban's knowledge
expertise as it relates to najee harris
no we didn't i mean we have you know we
have several contacts there if we you
know usually we won't
get into contacting a head coach unless
there's really one specific question i
mean those guys have to deal with you
know
several players and hundreds of
different types of calls and you know
that's one part of their job and i'm
sure they would help if need be
but we're very sensitive to the head
coaches availability and time and and
occasionally we will reach out but most
often we do not
when people try to
understand what went wrong with the
steelers running game last year there
are different
reasons different factors that could be
pointed to the fact that you used your
first round pick on a running back
i think would cause an objective
observer to say well they must not have
felt good enough about the guys they had
so they upgraded there is that a fair
assessment of what was wrong last year
that you just needed to upgrade the
quality of the players well we think you
know anytime you talk about the running
game you talk about what starts up front
you talk about your receivers being able
to get open your quarterback being able
to complete passes having a a
well-rounded passing game that opens up
things for the running back in addition
to having a capable runner we had
capable runners last year
our offensive line went through a
transition
and you know hopefully we're going to
come out the other side of it but it's
comprehensive and when we had the the
opportunity to take a guy like naji we
think that will help significantly with
our run game
jerome bettis had some comments to ed
bouchet of the athletic last year that
resonated with me bettis said the
running game is something that starts in
training camp the commitments in
training camp the mindset the blocking
everything that goes along with it if
you don't have it from day one it's hard
to pick it up halfway through the season
was that part of the problem last year
that maybe the commitment wasn't there
from the outset of training camp for
whatever reason
no i mean honestly you know going into
the season um we were very successful we
we got to an 11-0 mark doing what we
were doing
and then we didn't i mean we didn't we
didn't play well down the stretch i'll
be at the running game not being up to
par the passing game not being what it
was in the beginning and of course the
defense not being what it was so
we were successful offensively uh albeit
without
a real devastating run game and in the
end it was it ended up being the worst
in the league and that of course is part
of you know our failures down the
stretch but ultimately it's a
three-phase thing and we have to improve
in every phase
there are many kevin who believe that no
teams should take a running back in
round one that they can be gotten in any
round they can be gotten undrafted like
an aryan foster or most recently a james
robinson what traits do you need to see
before you will
put a running backs name on a card in
round one as opposed to addressing
another area of need
yeah i mean i don't buy into that we
don't buy into that
belief
uh at all
again if a player we think is a is a
very good player at the collegiate level
and we think he can be a very good
player
at the nfl level regardless of the
position i will we'll take him in that
first round if he's available
i've said it before i've been in round
two hall of fame running backs that were
both first round picks in jerome bettis
and barry sanders and you know we were
fortunate on each team to have those
people
with us so we don't buy into that you
know the only true value i search for is
how many games can we win and can these
players help us win a super bowl
is using a first round pick on a running
back an indication that this guy's going
to come in he's going to play he's going
to be on the field every down we're
basically going to use this guy because
we invested so much in getting it yeah
usually with your first round pick you
know into your second sometimes your
third rounders you want them to be three
down backs and you know that'll be up to
coach tomlin and his staff
as to how quickly nazi gets on the field
and how much they use them but we do
know that he's capable of playing all
three downs and that'll just be worked
out throughout the summer
one of the worst kept secrets leading
into the draft was the idea that the
steelers were looking running back a lot
of mock drafts had the steelers linked
to naji harris
how nervous were you as the picks were
coming off the board that someone was
potentially going to jump the steelers
at 24 and get him before you could yeah
it was really nothing we could do i mean
we knew we weren't trading up we needed
all of our draft capital
um
throughout the draft and we we made a
decision we won't be trading up we also
made a decision that if certain players
are there we won't trade away from them
and nazi was one of those players
so
really we lay it out and we know what
order we would take 24 players that
could get to us
um and in in the order that we would
take them so
we just wait it out if we have to trade
up like we did in a couple years ago for
devon bush then maybe we do it or trade
back but
we just waited it out and if knowledge
was there he was going to be our pick we
were certain about that
one of the big questions for the
steelers off season and it seems like it
was resolved so long ago because so much
has happened in the league over the last
three months was the future of ben
roethlisberger
is it the team's anticipation that it's
one more year with big ben or is it
let's just get through this year and see
where we go from here yeah i think ben's
mindset is he's focused on 2021 as we
all are and i think we all go into it
and we we focus now we see where things
lead but beyond that none of us know and
uh obviously ben's at the in the back
end of his career
he was terribly disappointed the way
we ended the way he ended and you know
shortly after the end of the season he
came to us and said listen i want
i want to be back you know of course we
had to work out some things
contractually and and honestly he set
off a nice little surge for us because
we had several players that were able to
come back to us but ben led the way by
taking that pay cut
and you know the steelers strike me as
one of the teams that when the
organization says we're trying to win
the super bowl every year it's not just
a gimmick to sell tickets it's not just
an understanding that the chances of
winning it any year are slim it seems to
me like the steelers go all in every
year was the roethlisberger signing that
indication that without question that's
the goal this year that we think we have
the talent we think we can address the
issues from last season and get over the
hump in 2021 well we know i mean the
goal will never change i mean you know
you're either you're either winning a
super bowl if if you don't you failed
and we know that having been on our team
in 2021 gives us a better chance than
not having been on our team because he
is he's still a significant player
we think he can still play at a high
level and hopefully we've got the talent
around him to help him do that
how does having a 17th game in the
regular season this year affect your job
as the person responsible for
picking the players getting them on the
roster knowing which guys are going to
be able to play 17 and what plans you
have to have in place in the event that
some can't
you know what that's an unknown to all
of us um
we know what 16 is like
we know what a four pre game preseason
is like leading into 16 but none of us
know what a three game preseason will be
like leading into 17 you know we play
four because of the hall of fame game
this year but i think we'll all be
learning
that
how to manage
this but it'll be it's going to be a new
endeavor for everybody
the steelers are a model of consistency
and continuity in the nfl that's no
surprise mike tomlin got a contract
extension earlier this offseason there's
still a group of fans that get riled up
easily when there's adversity and they
want to change coaches and that
surprises me because so many coaches
around the league have immense respect
for what mike tomlin has been able to do
what do you say to the fans out there
who just seem to have this quick trigger
that when things aren't going well we
got to change the coach in pittsburgh
well you know i think that's just the
territory that we live in and honestly
mike it's our own expectations are much
higher than anything from the outside as
you mentioned before
super bowls are all we measure ourselves
by so when we come up short we we feel
we feel and we we don't feel good for a
whole year until we get another chance
to try it again so any any external
uh type pressure really doesn't bother
us as much as the internal uh pressures
that we put on ourselves to put the best
team out there to try to win a super
bowl
how surprised were you that the way the
dominoes fell juju's miss shuster ended
up sticking around in pittsburgh for at
least another year we knew we felt going
into this off season with the you know
with the cap going down it was going to
be a difficult road for a lot of free
agents and we felt that there was
probably going to be a lot of short-term
deals because players would want to get
back out there
you know and test the market again next
year when hopefully the cap goes up so
we always left the door open we know we
encouraged our players look find out
what's out there do the best you can and
then you know call us keep us in the
loop and maybe we can figure something
out so in juju's case
uh it was great that you know we were
able to keep him with us because as we
mentioned earlier he can help
us and he can help ben uh try to win a
super bowl
one of the big drawbacks for last year
from the steelers perspective is hardly
any fans at the games because of the
local rules and regulations do you know
anything at this point about what
locally and across the state in
pennsylvania the rules are going to be
for fan attendance or at least the
expectation for fan attendance when
september rolls around no we're all just
very hopeful that again things return to
normal not just for
our fans or our game or baseball or
hockey you know obviously there's a lot
more important
life issues that that need to be you
know solidified as well so we'll always
you know adhere to the protocols we keep
our fingers crossed that we can
get back to full stadiums and you know
it's a more
you know it's a more a viable lively
event and you know again if we can
achieve that without
um
endangering our fans or our players and
great
i spoke with juju smith schuster
recently and i asked him about his
comment from from before the playoff
game against cleveland the browns is the
browns and the lessons he's learned from
that what lessons if any and he was very
candid with me that he understands that
it motivated the browns when he said
what he said what lessons do you want
the players to learn from that moment
and the ways that an opponent can get
itself riled up a little bit more based
upon the things that are said in the
media well again all we can look at is
the result of the game you know
cleveland played a great game against us
in the playoffs and they won and we went
home so we always will look back on what
didn't we do correct
to get the result that we wanted so we
all learn from every aspect of that and
you know juju can speak for himself on
that matter but again we always look at
each other we look at ourselves and say
what did what could we do better so
they're not have the same result
schedule release is coming next
wednesday what's the first thing you
look at when the steelers schedule drops
honestly it's just who who's who's
number one who will be opening up with
beyond that none of us can
we can't focus on anything else but the
opener um we're all going to play eight
home games we're all going to play eight
away games
that doesn't bother us
how there's how they're scheduled
we have no control over so let's just
see who's number one and let's let's
start focusing on that opening game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports